what's up fam hey man
i gotta start today talking about
our sister uh our queen
somebody's daughter somebody sister
cousin
friend girlfriend a citizen
a 26 year old young woman that had her
whole life ahead of her in a world of
potential
and a world of potential that you cannot
put a price on and i'm of course talking
about brianna taylor
um within the last hour i don't know if
you got a chance to catch it mike
but we had a moment we had a significant
moment
in this movement for black lives
um not only did they say her name
but they humanized her um
her mother spoke uh attorney benjamin
crump spoke
uh tamika mallory spoke
but mayor greg fischer really led the
way in terms of just
establishing uh compassion
and recognition that that her life did
indeed matter and so
they settled for 12 million dollars
uh dwarfs the highest payout that the
city
has ever paid in relation to actions by
louisville police
attorney crum talked about it being the
biggest settlement in america for
a black woman black person uh when it
comes to wrongful death at the hands of
police and and if i if i could mike
before
before i hand it off to you man i just
want to go ahead go ahead go ahead
go ahead i just want to focus on just
like what this moment
meant not just for the victims of police
brutality
not just for the black community in
general but specifically this was a
moment for black women
and not just black women like you know
sandra bland but
you know who who are often
overlooked even in this movement even in
this uh this racial reckoning
reckoning excuse me still overlooked you
know
we talked about you know black men being
targets or
or black men being hunted by police and
and black women even casually and it's
not often intentional
but even subconsciously just still get
kind of pushed
you know to the back and get
marginalized even though they've always
led these movements
um and carried our culture quite frankly
um you know to say i was moved would be
an understatement just watching
uh the discussion around these uh this
this decision to
to uh to award a 12 million dollar
settlement
in a wrongful death lawsuit to her um
you know it just was uh it was powerful
it was powerful um to to see a
a a a a black woman and again whose
experience
at the intersection of racism and sexism
you know um is often
under appreciated un uh unrecognized and
overlooked far too often in our society
in general but to see
uh you know a black woman in her life
and and her unfortunate uh and an
an an avoidable and untimely death
matter not just in terms of
humanizing her um
and the civil award we'll talk about
criminals separately but the civil award
the record
not record but the you know
groundbreaking if you will
civil award that our family received but
also man
the the the substantial police reform
that's coming with it
um you know there's there's some
sweeping changes which will get into
specifics
about uh that the louisville police um
department is is going to undertake as a
result of this uh no knock warrant
leading to the
the killing or the murder of brianna
taylor in our own apartment
six months ago but it was a powerful
moment and i and i
to be honest with you i kind of
struggled uh you know for the worse guy
was just moved watching the grace
now uh that are that her mother um
attorney crump
um um
that even the mayor displayed in uh and
how they how they described her uh today
so it was it was
the last hour has been it's been
meaningful
it's been meaningful like i said it was
a moment in this movement man
mike you're not struggling with the
words at all i think what you just said
here
uh leading off uh this show is is
extremely
powerful and you use the word
that i think is important to talk about
in this case and that word is compassion
so you said they humanized her they
showed great compassion
and my question uh for you and my
question for everybody else is can you
teach compassion
can you legislate compassion because
that's what this is all about and i get
so frustrated at times mike
in these times that we're not just this
these times i mean this is this has been
going on
longer than i've been alive uh for for
really the history of of political
discussion political discourse
is how a very simple issue becomes a
political issue
and if you are on one side
of the aisle if you have one letter
after your name you feel like you have
to take a certain position
you got to be for something or against
something and i just look at it this way
compassion is what it's all about think
of it this way
if you are uncomfortable with the
politics of this conversation
just in terms of good government
the city of louisville which i'm sure
like a lot of other cities right now
are struggling the city of louisville
has
paid out 20 million dollars
because they have been sloppy 20 million
dollars in the last eight years
they paid for the 12. right that's
before the 12 today
before the 12th so i'm saying 12 plus 8.
so 8 million
in 2012 because a man was wrongly
imprisoned for nine years because a
detective
perjured himself he lied so they figured
out nine years
imprisoned he was awarded
eight million dollars that's bad
government
now brianna taylor rest in peace
rest in power 12 million dollars to that
family
because you look at the look at the case
and step by step
this was supposed to happen yet this
happened there was supposed to be an
ambulance there nearby
but uh an hour before uh the the raid
the the ambulance was called away
somewhere else
no knock warrant was supposed to be
switched to something else but
the message was lost it's just sloppy so
it's not just about a certain complexion
it's not just about a certain race
if you are a citizen you look at this
and you are a fool if you think
well that's happening on the other side
of town but it won't happen for us
that's something for somebody else to
worry about but i never have to worry
about it i'm telling you if you are a
citizen in this country
and you look at that and you look at
that lack of attention to detail but
more
more intimately if you look at that lack
of compassion michael smith
that's an issue that's a real problem
yeah
um so sunday marks six months
and since she'd been killed in their own
home
and so another day means justice is
further delayed and therefore further
denied
now i believe the grand jury is um
deliberating this week and let's go to
the political part of it now because you
have the kentucky
attorney general daniel cameron who is
nothing short of in the pocket of mitch
mcconnell
and for another 50 days god willing our
president
um you know as everybody
stressed in this press conference today
and as anybody with any
again compassion and and good sense
knows that a civil settlement
is separate and apart from the criminal
proceedings
and you know we've just seen these
movies too many times
before to not worry that we know how
this is going to end
which is either with
you know no charges
or lesser charges or if they if these
officers are charged and arrested
will they will they be acquitted at
trial and while
look 12 million dollars certainly
couldn't come close to approximating
the value of rihanna taylor's life it's
substantial
but it's not enough and i say it's not
enough is in there is no amount
um you know it's partial justice but but
true justice
if you could call it justices more
accountability accountability
because nothing's going to bring her
back accountability
coming in the form of prison for these
officers
is a long way away uh tamika even
you know called for if for some reason
the chargers
chargers are not brought against these
officers she called for the mayor to
fire
the officers i mean that feels like
i feel like i should have been done
almost almost immediately but but okay
but even then it's just we're not going
to be satisfied
until a lesson until these officers
are brought to you know best we can get
in this country
justice but even then it's still going
to feel somewhat it's it's
yeah i'll go back to i'll go back to the
way you started you talked about
uh somebody who had their had their life
in front of him 26 years old
you know trying to trying to better her
situation and then that is interrupted
one night with this with this battering
ram
at the door you know you're you you have
a date night with your with your
boyfriend
you're in bed you're asleep and then
this chaos breaks out and the
the uh the boyfriend thinks it's the
ex-boyfriend
who they were looking for that's who the
police officers were looking for
the ex-boyfriend but there's so many
other questions here mike and i and i
know
we could talk about this we're going to
bookmark it but there are so many
questions here and it comes
back to it comes back to two things it
comes back to how you view people
and how you view government you're gonna
have a democracy or not
you don't wanna have a democracy just
say that don't call it a democracy
if you're not going to act like that so
what i'm saying is
her ex-boyfriend was
was involved in drugs but michael smith
we're not talking about frank lucas here
there is no way
that even if he's involved in all of the
things that
he was alleged and and proven to be
involved with
there is no way that you take this
approach with people it's too risky
now that's what they're saying with the
reform well we should have done this we
should have noticed
why does it take the death of brianna
taylor for you to use your common sense
that's just common sense yeah so beyond
beyond race beyond politics
we got to look at it that way what is
the most sensible way
to to be in a society and to take care
of one another
that's i'm going to put a bookmark in it
go ahead
i'm going to put that that's my last
point on it okay uh among
well you might want to respond to what
i'm about to say so i won't owe you to
that
but among the reforms from police uh
you know they're going to have a
commander approve
all search warrants before they go to a
judge
um you know there's this drug and
alcohol testing
requirements or increased requirements
as relates to police involved in
shootings or what have you incentives
for officers to live in the city
there are a few more substantive and
substantial reforms i must say that
sounded really good and sounded
meaningful but i do want to go back to i
just hope that
and while this family deserves this
restitution and more
i just hope that you know
daniel cameron again clearly compromised
by his relationship with the gop
but if he can if he is able to find it
in his heart to bring
charges to to do what's right and and
arrest the officers who killed brianna
taylor
i hope that this settlement isn't
conflated and it isn't somehow
seen by the people whose hands this
decision is in i hope they don't see it
as
you know anyway compromising the
credibility of the case or their ability
to win this case in court
by saying oh well you know the family
accepted a payout so there's your
justice
or how far what what is the family's
testimony how credible is the testimony
look i'm not a lawyer
don't get me wrong but i'm just i just
hope that people understand that this
civil
settlement and i don't know if this this
qualifies as an implicit or even an
explicit
acknowledgment of wrongdoing because the
initial
um the initial suit alleged that her
life was
wrongfully taken that there was
excessive force and gross
negligence as you described a minute ago
in detail i just hope that the
proceedings aren't compromised
by people who are already predisposed
to you know not recognizing that her
life mattered and not
bringing charges against these officers
and the last thing i'll say
let you know we we both have a lot of
last things on this because there's a
lot we can say
immediately that's right that's right
mike we're talking about accountability
we're talking about reform we just
it's just disheartening that these
things happen in the first place for no
other reason in the color of these
victims skin
it's like how to like you know
responding to it and reacting to it and
reforming
policies accordingly is like is that is
after the fact
like getting to a point where we can
somehow
stop police officers from
feeling like they have the authority
granted to them by the state to
murder and destroy black and brown
bodies of
men and as i started off by saying and
women women
getting to that point where we can
prevent those actions and not be in a
position to try to get
some form of justice on the back end
after they've already been taken from us
because an officer quote unquote feared
for his or her life
or because an officer acting acted
negligent in a way that they don't do
more often than not with white suspects
or white citizens is the case maybe
so yeah it's it's a lot it's a lot of
work to be done but this is this was
this was a mile in the marathon as the
attorney uh lanita baker said this is
the first mile on the marathon you know
mike it is a lot
and uh the last thing i'll say for now
let's put it that way the last thing
i'll say for now is that you met
daniel cameron i don't care what party
you represent
i do not care i love politics i've been
a student of politics since
as long as i can remember just love it i
i love the the political process and i
love that we're in a country
where uh your vote does matter and
it is a democracy i love that part of it
but i don't care about your pop
your party i don't care about your
career if you make
a decision in the name of your career
over human law over what's right
over morality then that's something
you're gonna have to live with and
and i'm hopeful it's something you'll be
haunted by
for the rest of your life because i
think that is unconscionable if you got
to take that approach listen
uh one thing about uh briana taylor this
brianna taylor
that name that name is familiar to a lot
of people who weren't aware of the
situation because
nba players decided yeah they were going
to say her name
nba players debated didn't they debate
mike about
going to that bubble you're 100 you're
100 right
you're 100 right mike and uh it's gonna
be interesting to see
what they have to say later on we got a
lot more to say
about this we got a lot more to discuss
it's day two
and we're already off to a pretty heavy
start a brother from another so
instead of trying to transition big mike
let's go ahead and just take a break
take a breath
y'all come on back and we gonna pick up
where we left off and we're gonna start
talking about uh what's going on in the
nba bubble but we don't live in a bubble
we got to recognize what's really going
on in our world
and again a powerful meaningful moment
in this movement for black lives 12
million dollars to the family of brianna
taylor
you